- It's difficult when we're
in front of a mirror everyday,
but that mirror is not there
for us to criticize our bodies
in a negative way.
It's there for us to be
able to see our line,
to realize if our hips are
square, if we're not sickling,
you know, all of these
things to improve ourselves,
not to put ourselves down.
And it's really difficult when
you're a part of something
that over time, throughout
history, has become,
you know, there are so many
negative things attached to
being a ballet dancer, you know,
when people hopefully not
to this day, but you know,
a lot of the time in the
past when people think
of ballet dancers, they
think oh they don't eat,
they have eating disorders,
they're this, they're that.
I think that it's important for us
to understand that we are athletes,
and that's why I emphasize that so much.
Not to make us seem less than,
or that athletes are better,
but we have to take care of
our bodies in the same way
that athletes do, it's
how we fuel our bodies,
it's what we're putting into it,
that's what keeps us dancing
for a long period of time,
and hopefully not getting
injured as often as,
sometimes it just happens,
but it's so important for us to remember
that being healthy and
fit is going to make us
the best dancers that we can be.